we teamed up with go rving to travel
from dallas to waco which is such a
beautiful drive and you know there are
so many non-traditional trips that you
can take with your rv and this road trip
with barrymore was anything but
conventional wait till you see this
[Music]
hello texas
drew look here we are at trinity
overlook park the dallas skyline behind
us this is a dream come true for me i
have always wanted to go rving and i
know that you are an expert i've been
rving since i had a driver's license
there really is no better way to travel
well i have some stipulations if we're
going to go on an rv trip okay
number one we need good road trip snacks
like um beef jerky yes that's exactly
what i'm thinking i can't road trip
without beef jerky duh and number two
can i drive well i'm used to driving but
i'll be in your passenger seat any day
of the week
my big rig awaits let's start a little
beef jerky first just for energy say rv
on three one two three army
i have a mouthful of jerky i couldn't
say it
yeah
we're actually driving at five miles an
hour can you believe that all right
let's do this
excuse me
i think we're getting on a freeway this
is going to be a moment you're
graduating we went from side street to
freeway real quick
what are road trip games i should have
googled it remember i spying
all right let's play i spy how does it
work again i see something you have to
figure out what it is which is going to
be hard
to drive
i'm going to win by
it doesn't work
do you want to count how many times i
get honked at
that was one
i love that nod that people do like this
when you drive by someone like you ever
do that and like a one hand up wave
it gives
i love that you're all sun shiny and hi
everybody and i love you
put a steering wheel in front of me and
i turn into the exorcist
oh
can we try this barbecue yes of course
hello
hi
we want some barbecue
so what makes your barbecue so delicious
well we're famous for the brisket and we
were voted one of the top 50 in texas
monthly how does texas do barbecue oh
texas-style barbecue is probably the
best why it is smoked meat can we try
some barbecue oh my
god look at this
oh
no no a tisket a tasket put some brisket
in my basket
[Music]
oh my god it's incredible
thank you so much i feel like i could
eat the whole thing
we'll just wrap up that whole brisket to
go think exactly
[Music]
where's your favorite place you've ever
gone rv joshua tree when there was a
meteor shower wow
you know i used to go camping with my
parents all the time growing up and i
would love like sleeping in the the rv
sitting out by the campfire
my parents just
getting drunk that's about the only
thing i relate to about any of this
scenario
what is the most romantic movie ever
breakfast at tiffany's
trying to think of like
my favorite kiss too
kissing is so hot it totally is oh my
god you know my first kiss with welly
was like 45 minutes after we met shut up
i love it why waste time get in there
are we still in texas
hello waco
all right
[Applause]
thank you for making my rv dreams come
true oh my god you're so welcome one
last selfie
[Music]
[Applause]
ready thank you
for helping us take not only such a fun
trip but helping me realize my dreams of
talking about this on this show i know
and my dream come true i was driving
that you all see me driving that army
that's right i did
with my girl by my side and the open
road out there and for all of you at
home rving is for everyone even people
who don't see them maybe as the typical
rver people like me you can trust me
you've got to try it it's so true
[Music]